buckle up tonight former mini mike
bloomberg's campaign
we can officially report is on life
support with a respirator and feeding
tube
with little to no hope of recovery he
was
literally ripped to shreds in last
night's debate
i can't really overstate how poorly he
performed the single
worst debate performance i have ever
witnessed in my lifetime
frankly he embarrassed himself and
anyone who supports him but mostly
himself
as well he's his only really big donor
take a look mr bloomberg had policies
in new york city of stop and frisk which
went after african-american
and latino people in an outrageous way
that is not a way you're going to grow
voter turnout
i'd like to talk about who we're running
against a billionaire
who calls women fat broads and
horse-faced lesbians
and no i'm not talking about donald
trump i'm talking about mayor bloomberg
we need something different than donald
trump i don't think you look at donald
trump and say
we need someone richer in the white
house the mayor says that he has a great
record that he's done these wonderful
things
well the fact that the fact of the
matter is he has not managed
his city very very well when he was
there he didn't get a whole lot done he
had stop and frisk
throwing close to five million young
black men up against the wall
we have a very few non-disclosure
agreements
how many let me finish how many is that
none of them accuse me of doing
anything other than maybe they didn't
like the joke i told
uh that's like a dana white mma beat
down
now you can buy a lot of things with 500
million dollars you really can
but you can't buy a personality you
can't buy charisma and apparently you
can't even buy good debate preparation
in two short hours this never-ending
slick 500
million dollar marketing campaign
collapsed before the entire country's
eyes
cover the new york post called it a
brutal beat down
even the far left tabloid the new york
daily news compared it to a massive
explosion
political writing that it was a
monumental
failure in terms of preparation the
liberal daily beast this is their
headline
quote bloomberg spends hundreds of
millions of dollars to get his ass beat
cnbc reporting bloomberg took a beating
former obama official van jones compared
bloomberg
to the sinking of a titanic you know
when it hit the iceberg
even msdnc wacko missed a thrill up his
leg obamagasm chris matthews compared
him to a prize fighter
who couldn't stop bleeding and didn't
have any cut man in his corner to stop
the bleeding for him
and according to even fake news cnn
quote
it's unanimous a horrible night for
bloomberg you get the picture
so the democrats plan b is an
unmitigated disaster it imploded
last night and with biden and blueberg's
epic
implosion there's no plan c last night's
debate did prove one thing the
democratic party
is in a state of complete and utter
chaos and a meltdown and it's only going
to get worse take a look
we're going to talk about votes in the
senate in washington let's talk about it
i want to talk about maybe this is
appropriate can i just defend
senator klobuchar for a minute this is
not right
all right let's see you have a devout
soviet-style socialist leading the way
a wall street billionaire that thinks
anybody can be a farmer a harvard law
professor has been faking her race for
three decades
couple of other sociopaths who are
hell-bent on fame and glory
it's like a sick twisted joke
the weakest presidential field frankly
in the history of american politics
and last night it was essentially a
circular firing squad
all showing their true colors i couldn't
write it any better take a look
most americans don't see where they fit
if they've got to choose between
a socialist who thinks that capitalism
is the root of all evil
and a billionaire who thinks that money
ought to be the the root of all power
so what we are saying pete is maybe it's
a time
for the working class of this country to
have a little bit of power in washington
rather than your billionaire campaign
contributors
it's not a plan it's a powerpoint and
amy's plan
is even less it's like a post-it note
insert plan here
the only company we can't go after or
gun manufacturing
here but that's the difference and you
know what you have not been in the arena
doing that work
you've memorized a bunch of talking
points and a bunch of things
ouch you can see a total bloodbath but
through the shouting the infighting and
the identity politics we did learn
that these well insane people who want
to be your next president are actually
pretty dumb and their policies are even
more chilling take a look
nbc did a poll yesterday it says joe
biden
is best equipped to beat donald trump
that's what your opponent said
you're literally in part of the
committee that's overseeing these things
and we're not able to speak to literally
the first thing about the politics
of the country to ourselves are you
trying to say that i'm dumb
or are you mocking me here pete so maybe
judge the tax code
why are you complaining what wrote the
the best known socialist in the country
happens to be a millionaire with three
houses what i miss here
well you'll miss that i work in
washington house
that's the first problem live in
burlington house too that's good
and like thousands of other vermonters i
do have a summer camp
forgive me for that all right
says
[Applause]
ah yes bolshevik bernie sanders a
soviet-style
socialist millionaire with three houses
who wants to eliminate all capitalism
now listen closely because what i'm
about to tell you well it should shock
you to your core
bolshevik bernie sanders is the
democratic party's front-runner
now this is what i've been saying the
new radical extreme democratic socialist
party of america
now that's the same guy who wants the
federal government to let's see
confiscate your private property
confiscate your private wealth
nationalize our entire energy industry
i'll eventually get off oil and gas
completely
that's the lifeblood of the world's
economy nationalize your
health care industry how did obamacare
work out put a cap on the amount of
money
americans are actually allowed to earn
dramatically raise taxes on
oh everyone making over 29 000 a year
that means anybody the same guy who's he
prays on almost every single communist
dictator around the globe the same guy
who
actually can't make it up he honeymoon
my first thought in the former soviet
union the communist soviet union and now
that whack job
78 year old pseudo-communist well he
could very well be the democratic
nominee but tonight we can
report it seems unlikely that bolshevik
bernie will get the delegates needed to
win the nomination outright
which means this ultimate shift show is
going to get much worse
buckle up odds are high we are headed to
a contested convention
top democrats are now plotting a way to
rip this nomination from bernie's cold
socialist hands and in fact at last
night's debate
no candidate on stage except for
bolshevik bernie
agreed that the primary winner should go
to the candidate with the most votes of
the people
they all agree that the process should
play out so super delegates in other
words
democratic hierarchy they have more say
at the convention
on the second ballot than the people
that actually go out and vote and caucus
so that's right some of the very same
people by the way
including elizabeth warren and mayor
pete who want to eliminate the electoral
college now want a rig convention
they want to steal the nomination away
from bernie yet again so buckle up brace
yourselves
because we are only months away from
political chaos like we have never
witnessed before
this is basically the appetizer this is
just the opening salvo if you will
a preview of coming attractions the only
question tonight is will
bolshevik bernie take this lying down
like he did in 2016.
well he and his supporters let the dnc
slap him around yet again
or will democrats descend into a full-on
civil war
i can't predict the future make no
mistake none of us should take any
election for granted
stakes are way way too high for we the
american people
anything can happen but last night's
debate did have a clear winner
and it was not anyone on that stage even
minnie mike the farmer bloomberg sees
the writing is on the wall take a look
so how was your night last night
look the real winner in the debate last
night was donald
trump because i worry that we may very
well be on the way to nominating
somebody who cannot win
in november and if we choose a candidate
who appeals to a small base like senator
sanders it will be a fatal error
well farmer mike may be right democrats
are now limping into nevada then south
carolina
right around the corner super tuesday
this is going to get bloodier and uglier
real fast and with the republicans
clearly all united around president
trump his campaign has never been
stronger